all right Rangers our plan of attack is
simple halo drop into scourge city fire
a whole mess of bullets and take Jake
into custody so we can become a time for
wahoo mm-hmm Mike my hardy Rob what's up
what's up
we both saw Ratchet and Clank the movie
mm-hmm you were reviewing it for
GameSpot yeah overall weren't too jazzed
about it no I didn't like it yeah at all
I know it's unfortunate yeah pointing
yeah this will be a spoiler free review
and we're gonna talk about the movie
itself is you know it's hard to
basically separate the two because the
game and the movie are really similar
but we'll do our best to basically give
the movie as own merit I guess first off
what was like one of your main gripes
with the movie it felt like an
afterthought it felt very much like a
first draft I feel like it didn't go
through too many revisions after they
had the initial just basic plot layout
and basic kind of the dialogue felt like
it was just kind of phoned in at the
last second I didn't really you know
it's hard not to compare the game of
movie which I don't want to do but the
people that are seeing this movie will
primarily know Rush and Clank from video
games this is the first time the
property is in you know like in film so
as someone who has played the games
going into I was excited for it because
I'm playing expecting the charm and the
animation this movies are really good
but I just I really felt like the the
story itself was too brushed and I felt
like a lot of it was just there to
advance the plot which wasn't
interesting enough on its own one of my
initial gripes was the fourth wall
breaking dimension of like you know
making fun of itself being self-aware a
man with a dream actually I'm alone
that's fine alone box with a dream there
was some of that in the beginning of the
movie and I felt like at some point it
just stopped so many things felt
half-baked
I felt the same way about like the humor
some of the jokes are really funny
especially voice acting with Paul
Giamatti was great so that's just alone
the few lines he did have
Victor I believe he was used funny but
like to me the jokes were over explained
I know like a lot of John Goodman jokes
they lingered too long on them and then
like it's like them nothing you saying
did you get that joke for those who
don't know ratchet is the LOB back so
that the animal that looks like a cat
mouse thing and Clank is the robot and
they are that they were going for a
dynamic where Clank is pretty like this
intelligent more you know left brain one
where ratchets happy-go-lucky he doesn't
care he's more of like the robe one and
I didn't really see that come through at
all I didn't feel like I think me and
you kind of both had the same impression
that ratchet Clank didn't even share
that much screen time maybe like maybe
20 minutes tops and there's like a good
like almost like a buddy cop drama
hidden in this but the while the
structure is there I didn't feel like
there's any substance to any
relationships in the movie with
absolutely it's an animated movie like
which it's not like trying to tell a
heavy story but I still would have liked
more entertaining dialogue and get any
of that so yeah those two felt like they
had a lot of time wasted retching Clank
and then moving on to other characters
Captain Clark
the movie almost felt like it was more
about him yes which was really
frustrating considering he's just like
this narcissistic oh yeah it doesn't he
doesn't add much to it he's like that
kind of who's that character that
they're reminding you they're not taking
himself seriously with it's like we're
right there with you watching this movie
but at the same time he doesn't add
anything like I've substance to anything
I'm not I'm not expecting like
oscar-worthy writing but it was still it
would have been nice for them to linger
on a scene for longer than like 30
seconds it's very much star wars in the
plot this isn't a spoiler or anything
but they develop this weapon to destroy
planets but also like to build a new one
in their place so like for like vacation
resorts or just to like I want to plan
it but every time they like showed the
planet they would jump between planets
would be like this this establishing
shot of the planet and then they would
jump into these really close shots of
these characters would this really stale
dialogue and I never really got a sense
of where they were and why they were
there it was just it was almost like it
was trying to make room for just the
animation to do the talking but I didn't
feel like the animation did that it was
every single scene started with pretty
wild music playing and then it was these
people talking over like just explaining
everything to us there was never any
time where they just actually let me
enjoy watching this movie which it's a
pretty good looking movie but I don't
feel as if there's any like movement
worth watching yeah but I will say I
don't feel like it ever any of the
characters changed they're all pretty
static the times they did change was
just on a whim cork we're just almost
randomly without explanation do this or
feel this and then we just kind of have
to accept it and move on with the movie
I never felt like any of the characters
are interacting in any like entertaining
ways
so overall kind of a letdown yeah and I
was excited for it
some of who's like fan of the series I
went into the movie without like any
expectations of it but I still it looks
really good and there are some great
action sad moments I just wish they had
pushed some of those farther and I
didn't feel like anyone it did yeah
overall it felt rushed that's a shame
it's a good first draft yeah I'll say
that cool evolved yeah that's the review
we kept it as spoiler free as possible
your full review is on site yeah anybody
watching this if you want to go a little
more in-depth I guess it's good like the
written view goes a little more but I
avoid spoilers in that as well thanks
very much Mike thanks for chatting let's
scatter the cockroaches just push the
button set